und jetzt heißt es nochmal haltung
annehmen und hand aus der hose in etwas
mehr als einer stunde ist es soweit zum
ersten mal in der geschichte verlässt
ein land die europäische union und zwar
großbritannien genau partystimmung große
stimmung bei den exit fans aber auch in
brüssel findet heute um mitternacht wohl
eine symbolische aktion staat ja da wird
extra eine britische fan an einen
bestimmten brunnen gelegt ein bereits
als zeichen als zeigen ich muss sagen
ich sehe es anders ich finde es traurig
ich weiß nicht wie es eben geht ich
finds auch traurig denn es gibt so
vieles was man an den briten einfach
lieben muss die bilder jetzt wieder
hochkommen ihr legendäres rhythmusgefühl
wie hier theresa may versucht hat das
wort drexhage zu tanzen ihre
beneidenswerte debattenkultur im
unterhaus und natürlich immer wieder
ihre sportliche fairness hier ein
symbolbild für boris johnson politik
keine angst das kind ist tot
und das traurige ist obwohl er jetzt
noch diese übergangszeit kommen bis zum
ende des jahres in der wir einen
freihandelsvertrag mit denen aushandeln
müssen jetzt schon kostet der brh exit
arbeitsplätze ja wirklich ich zum
beispiel habe hier alleine drei autoren
angestellt und zwar nur für exit witze
was mache ich jetzt mit diesen leuten
das
es ist ein hartes business
sprache ihre gebühren von den von den
vielen grafiken hier mal ganz zu
schweigen hier wirklich jede woche einen
kracher nach dem anderen raushauen haben
wissen sie noch die toten hirne von
london oder der brh exorzist
und natürlich der klassiker planet der
insel ist alles vorbei alles vorbei
denn
man wird mir dann schon ich bin meiner
kunst übrigens ironie der geschichte
heute müssen sich die briten ein
allerletztes mal nach uns richten
drechselt ist um 0 uhr
mitteleuropäischer zeit des massakers ja
was passiert dann genau was 23 uhr
britischer zeit ist alle etwas komme
uhrzeit und deshalb sollte eigentlich
bigben dazu leuten statt des big ben
bongo das jetzt nur eine diaprojektion
in der downing street geben ist billiger
das fängt ja gut an muss ich sagen was
richtig richtig haltet euer geld mal
lieber zusammen ihr werdet es noch
brauchen
denn fakt ist die briten wickeln etwa
die hälfte ihres handelns mit eu-ländern
die hälfte und wie das dann gehen soll
eigene standards für natürlich
niedrigsteuern sie wollen eine
steueroase werden oder
arbeitnehmerrechte eigene
arbeitnehmerrechte aber weiter vom eu
binnenmarkt profitieren
wie das gehen soll das kann auch der
boris nicht erklären naja vielleicht
wird das alles noch viel viel teurer als
gedacht und weil bei uns in deutschland
tatsächlich kein mensch mehr bock hat
auf das thema exit konzentriert sich
inzwischen 97 prozent unserer england
berichterstattung auf den sogenannten
exit der max it sie wissen schon harry
und megan also der arbeitslose
zeitsoldat und die arbeitslose
schauspielerin
die haben ja quasi gekündigt bei der
queen die sind quasi abgehauen
es muss man muss man so sagen und
seitdem
seitdem wirklich nur noch schnappatmung
dürfen die das mit gerade mal mitte
dreißig ausziehen
bei der oma
oder wachsfigurenkabinett von madame
tussauds ist der bruch schon vollzogen
die sussex es stehen jetzt in der
bücherecke weit weg vom rest der
windsors oder das ist hat bücherecke
haben wir jetzt eben auf den bildern gar
nicht so gut gesehen aber die stehen da
tatsächlich neben hitler und stalin des
zu haben ja das geht soweit einfach nur
war sie gekündigt haben ich finde es
traurig vor allem die aggressionen die
mengen entgegenschlagen sind ja wenn man
darüber nachdenkt geradezu ein symbol
für diesen braig cit einen kulturkampf
zwischen einem weltoffenen modernen
england und der kleinen mäßigen insel
die lieber im eigenen genpool vor sich
hin gammelt reden wir drüber in einer
neuen folge von und die show royal ts
mit christian seel manieren
[Musik]
unser heute schon adelsexperte ist
menschlich enttäuscht ja christian
geradezu beleidigt wegen des max it kann
man wohl sagen welche das kann man wohl
sagen der familienbetrieb der winzer ist
das war auch die letzte erfolgsmarke der
bankrotten insel und plötzlich gibt es
diese unfassbare pressemitteilung der
queen zitat harry und mergel sind ab
sofort nicht mehr arbeiten der
mitglieder der königlichen familie
totaler schock
wussten sie dass einer von ihnen jemals
gearbeitet ich auch die arbeit was ist
denn das das ist nicht mehr mein
hochadel arbeit in diese leute wollen
wir doch unsere träume unsere sehnsüchte
projizieren dafür sind jedoch da die
sollen sich auf ihre kernkompetenzen
konzentrieren also polo und inzest was
soll denn da
dafür lieben wir sie doch dass sie so
völlig lebens und tüchtig sind hier ein
ex-sportler verpetzt prinz charles us to
face cream über die zahnpasta jeden
morgen auf die zahnbürste gedrückt und
seine schlafanzüge jeden morgen gebügelt
auch seine schnürsenkel müssen jeden
morgen gebügelt und geglättet werden
naja natürlich mit ungezügeltem
schnürsenkeln kommt ja keine drei
mitarbeiter bricht sich das genick alles
wunderbar eingespielte uralte rituale
und dann kommt da so eine b
schauspielerin aus hollywood und sprengt
die gruppe kein wunder dass die medien
sich so ein bisschen auf sie
eingeschossen haben merken war er die
treibende kraft hinter diesem wir wollen
in royale rente geht und halten sie
persönlich für eine inzwischen eine
gefährliche person harry sehen waren
darunter auch michael irgendwie legen
ist in vancouver und schockt häuser aber
ich glaube gleichzeitig dass jene
unfassbar selbst zentriert der
egoistische person ist meldet hat cage
zum weinen gebracht monster megan bricht
das herz der green monster meng was soll
denn das warum kriegt sie eigentlich
fast alles alleine ab weil sie die frau
ist
so ein erfahrungswert von mir
weiß es ja noch die frau schuldig ist ja
auch gar nicht der punkt dass da manche
leute jetzt rassismus reininterpretieren
das finde ich einfach lächerlich und was
man zugeben muss kate und merken werden
medial schon unterschiedlich dargestellt
hier
der britische express schreibt william
schenkt keltner avocado gegen die
morgenübelkeit und dann derselbe express
mergens geliebte avocado schuld an
menschenrechtsverletzungen dann halt
verschiedene avocados oder hier daily
mail
nicht mehr lange schwangere kate
streichelt zärtlich ihren babybauch und
dieselbe zeitung zu schwangeren mengen
warum kann mir nicht die finger von ihr
abzulassen
das hat aber rechtliche frage was soll
da ständige gefummelt ja wo man ist ein
gutes stichwort selbst der notgeile
prinz andrew kriegt weniger ab in der
britischen schweine presse ja ja das
kommt mal vor bei denen winzers dass
einer seinen kleinen prinzen nicht unter
kontrolle hat aber das spielt doch
letztlich keine rolle ich sage ihnen die
werden sich auch wieder berappeln weil
es ja letztlich ein
wirtschaftsunternehmen ist experten
schätzen den wert der marke winzer immer
noch auf 79 milliarden euro
was meinen sie was nicht verdienen mit
ihrem ganzen merchandising trifft teller
tassen royale nachttöpfe das ganze
programm
da können unsere bürgerlichen politiker
nicht war ein klingeln liegt doch alles
seit jahren wie blei bei uns im
heute-show fanshop der frank walter
steinmeier thermomix
das sei wichtig weil hier
die heiko maas beauty nachtcreme will
keiner und der größte laden wieder von
hallen das an japanische katzen deswegen
brauchen wir den
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
last ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen aber da